I WILL TELL YOU ABOUT IT
PRIVATELY.
TUCKER, THANK YOU.
GOOD SHOW.
>> Tucker: THANKS.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO HANNITY
TONIGHT.
IT IS CLEAR YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ELECTED A
WINNER.
THREE YEARS THE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION HOAX.
ILLEGAL FISHING EXPEDITION
AND TWO YEARS OF MUELLER’S
HYPER PARTISAN WITCH-HUNT.
MONTHS OF THE SCHUMER SCHIFF
SHAM SHOW AND NOW ACTUAL
REAL ACQUITTAL EXONERATION,
VINDICATION, THE PRESIDENT
REMAINS TOTALLY UNFAZED.
IN FACT, IS HE WINNING LIKE
NEVER BEFORE.
HIS AGENDA IS A MASSIVE
SUCCESS LIKE WE SAW ON
TUESDAY NIGHT.
LOOK AT THIS, A BRAND NEW
GALLUP POLL FINDING 90% OF
AMERICANS ARE SATISFIED WITH
THEIR PERSONAL LIFE.
I HOPE TO ONE DAY MAKE IT
100.
ECONOMIC CONFIDENCE IS AT
THE HIGHEST POINT SINCE THE
YEAR 2,000.
PRESIDENT TRUMP RACKING UP
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AT A
RECORD-SETTING PACE.
HIS APPROVAL NUMBERS, BY THE
WAY, LOOK AT THIS,ETTER
THAN EVER BEFORE.
THIS DESPITE THE FACT WATCH
THE SUCCESS.
THE EXACT ON SIFT THE BIDEN
OBAMA YEARS, FACING MORE
UNDUE RAGE AND RESISTANCE,
FRANKLY, THAN ANY PRESIDENT
IN HISTORY.
WATCH THIS.
>> WE HAVE BEEN GOING
THROUGH THIS NOW FOR OVER
THREE YEARS IT WAS EVIL.
IT WAS CORRUPT.
IT WAS DIRTY COPS.
IT WAS LEAKERS AND LIARS.
AND THIS SHOULD NEVER EVER
HAPPEN TO ANOTHER PRESIDENT,
EVER.
WE WENT THROUGH HELL,
UNFAIRLY.
DID NOTHING WRONG.
I HAVE DONE THINGS WRONG IN
MY LIFE.
I WILL ADMIT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> NOT PURPOSEFULLY BUT I
HAVE DONE THINGS WRONG.
BUT THIS IS WHAT THE END
RESULT IS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> EVERY TIME I WOULD SAY
THIS IS UNFAIR, LET’S GO TO
COURT.
THEY WOULD SAY SIR, YOU
CAN’T GO TO COURT.
THIS IS POLITICS.
AND WE WERE TREATED
UNBELIEVABLY UNFAIRLY YOU
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND WE FIRST
WENT THROUGH RUSSIA, RUSSIA,
RUSSIA.
IT WAS ALL [BLEEP]
>> Sean: AS YOU CAN SEE ONE
OF THE PRESIDENT’S GREATEST
STRENGTHS HIS ABILITY TO BE
SERIOUS AND, YET, IN SPITE
OF ALL OF, THIS ACTUALLY
EXTREMELY FUNNY, GIVEN THE
NONSTOP HYSTERIA OF THE LEFT
THAT YOU NEED TO HAVE A
SENSE OF HUMOR TO STAY SANE
THESE DAYS.
TODAY WE SAW A PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF THIS.
DURING HIS REMARKS ABOUT
MINORITY WHIP STEVE SCALISE,
REMEMBER HE WAS FATALLY --
HE WAS NOT FATALLY HE WAS
SHOT NEARLY FATALLY BY THAT
FAR LEFT MANIAC IN 2017.
WATCH THIS.
A MAN WHO IS BRAVER THAN ME.
BRAVER THAN ALL OF US IN
THIS ROOM HE GOT WHACKED,
STEVE, RIGHT.
I WENT TO THE HOSPITAL WITH
OUR GREAT FIRST LADY THAT
NIGHT, RIGHT, HONEY?
WE SAW A MAN THAT WAS NOT
GOING TO MAKE IT.
HE WAS NOT GOING TO MAKE IT.
HE WAS -- THE DOCTOR.
I TOLD HIM HIS WIFE.
I SAID SHE LOVES YOU.
WHY DO YOU SAY THAT?
BECAUSE SHE WAS DEVASTATED?
A LOT OF WIVES WOULDN’T GIVE
A DAMN.
LOOK LIKE HE HAD A 20, 25%
CHANCE.
I THINK YOU SET A RECORD FOR
BLOOD LOSS.
AND STEVE SCALISE, I
ACTUALLY, HONESTLY I THINK
YOU ARE BETTER LOOKING NOW.
YOU ARE MORE HANDSOME NOW.
YOU WEREN’T THAT
GOOD-LOOKING.
YOU LOOK GOOD NOW.
YOU ARE A WARRIOR.
STEVE, IS HE FANTASTIC.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT
THANKED SO MANY OTHER PEOPLE
WHO WENT TO WAR FOR HIM
THROUGHOUT ALL OF THESE
WITCH HUNTS AND LIES AND
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
THROUGH EVERY HOAX.
THROUGH EVERY SLANDER,
SMEAR, BESMIRCHMENT.
SCALISE WILL JOIN US IN JUST
A MOMENT.
WITHOUT A DOUBT, HE HAS BEEN
A KEY FIGURE IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST PELOSI’S RADICAL
REVENGEFUL AGENDA IN THE
HOUSE TONIGHT THAT AGENDA,
AGAIN, UTTERLY FAILING.
WHAT HAVE THEY DONE FOR WE,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE?
LOOK AT THIS.
THE EDITORIAL BOARD, THE
"WALL STREET JOURNAL"
CALLING PELOSI’S IMPEACHMENT
SHAM A, QUOTE SORRY, IN
CONGRESSIONAL HISTORY.
CONSTITUTIONAL SCHOLAR
JONATHAN TURLEY, HE DIDN’T
VOTE FOR DONALD TRUMP.
CALLING ON HER TO RESIGN.
HE’S RIGHT.
ON TUESDAY, A VERY ANGRY
NANCY PELOSI STAGING THIS
NATIONALLY TELEVISED NONSTOP
TEMPER TANTRUM IN WHAT IS A
PETTY, SMALL PETULANT
DISPLAY OF THIS RAGE, THIS
PSYCHOSIS, EMOTION.
REMEMBER WHEN NANCY PELOSI
RIPPING UP THE PRESIDENT’S
SPEECH, CALLING IT ALL A
PACK OF LIES?
REALITY, BY THE WAY, PELOSI
APPARENTLY WAS PLANNING THIS
STUNT ALL ALONG.
IN FACT, LOOK AT YOUR
SCREEN.
PELOSI ACTUALLY WAS LIKE
PRE-RIPPING EACH OF THE
PAGES THAT SHE ACTUALLY TOOK
THE TIME TO PREP THE RIP.
AND SHE PLANNED THE WHOLE
THING, OBVIOUSLY.
AND AS YOU CAN SEE HERE, SHE
EVEN TESTED THE RIPPABILITY
OF THE DOCUMENT DURING THE
SPEECH.
LOOK AT THIS, RIGHT THERE.
OH, I GUESS WE KNOW WHY
PETTY PELOSI WAS SO
DISTRACTED AND IT WAS WEIRD,
AND DISTRACTING AND MUMBLING
AND I’M LIKE, OKAY.
I GOT TO NOT FOCUS ON THAT
PART OF THE SHOW BECAUSE I
WANTED TO HEAR THE ADDRESS.
SHE WAS DOING IT THE WHOLE
ADDRESS.
APPEARS FOR THE BIG SHOW SHE
WAS PLANNING AFTER THE
PRESIDENT’S ADDRESS.
NOW, REMEMBER, THIS IS THE
VERY SAME PELOSI CLAIMING
THAT SHE DOESN’T HATE THE
PRESIDENT, NO.
SHE IS SO PRAYERFUL ABOUT IT
ALL AND SO SOMBER.
THIS MORNING THE PRESIDENT,
HE HAD THIS TO SAY ABOUT
PELOSI’S PRAYERS AND HE IS
DEAD-ON ACCURATE.
LISTEN.
>> COURAGEOUS REPUBLICAN
POLITICIANS AND LEADERS HAD
THE WISDOM, FORTITUDE AND
STRENGTH TO DO WHAT EVERYONE
KNOWS WAS RIGHT.
I DON’T LIKE PEOPLE WHO USE
THEIR FAITH AS JUSTIFICATION
FOR DOING WHAT THEY KNOW IS
WRONG.
NOR I DO LIKE PEOPLE WHO SAY
I PRAY FOR YOU, WHEN THEY
KNOW THAT THAT’S NOT SO.
>> Sean: PETTY PELOSI
PREPPED THE RIP.
TARGETING PELOSI.
ALSO SENATOR ROMNEY.
THIS WEEK ROMNEY SAYING HIS
DEEP FAITH LED HIM TO VOTE
TO REMOVE THE PRESIDENT.
QUID, PRO AND HUNTER AT THE
SAME TIME.
LIBERAL MORNING JOE PRAISING
ROMNEY’S HIGHER CALLING.
FAKE NEWS JIM ACROSS TAX
THAT’S RIGHT, CALLING IT A
PROFILE IN COURAGE.
FAR LEFT HACK JENNIFER RUBIN
WRITING ROMNEY IS A MAN OF
UNCOMMON DECENCY AND HONOR.
THE MEDIA MOB FAWNING OVER
ROMNEY ALL DAY.
I RECALL IT REALLY WASN’T
THAT LONG AGO THAT THAT SAME
MEDIA MOB WAS FALSELY
ACCUSING ROMNEY LET’S SEE OF
BEING A RACIST, A SEXIST,
MISOGYNIST AND TAX CHEAT AND
A FELON.
WELL, PIERRE DEFECT IT’S O
YOUR NEW FRIENDS, JUST A
REMINDER.
>> ONCE AGAIN MITT STEPPED
IN IT CALLING RUSSIA OUR
NUMBER ONE GEOPOLITICAL
ENEMY.
WHAT’S THIS THE EVIL EMPIRE
AGAIN?
>> HE ALSO HAD [INAUDIBLE]
EVERY MORNING.
>> IT’S GOING TO BE THE JOKE
THAT KEEPS ON GIVING.
>> CAN HE RELATE TO WORKING
WOMEN?
YOU KNOW, MADE IT SOUND
ALMOST LIKE WORKING WOMEN
ARE SOME MAIL ORDER PRODUCT.
>> ONE HUGE EXPLOSIVE WORD
OUT THERE JUST INCENDIARY,
VICTIMS.
>> IT WAS A CONDESCENDING,
UNBELIEVABLY INSENSITIVE WAY
OF INSULTING PEOPLE BY
CALLING THEM ALL VICTIMS.
>> Tucker: THESE ARE THE
PEOPLE ROMNEY NOW TRUSTS HIS
NEW FRIENDS AND NOT THE
PEOPLE WHO STEADFASTLY
DEFENDED HIM FROM THESE
FALSE ATTACKS FOR SO MANY
YEARS.
ROMNEY, OF ALL PEOPLE, WELL,
HAVE YOU DIMINISHED
YOURSELF, MITT, IT’S SAD.
IT’S TRAGIC.
AND YOU SHOULD HAVE KNOWN
THAT THE TRUTH MEANS NOTHING
TO THE MEDIA MOB AND THEIR
PARTNERS AND THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY THAT NOW LOVE YOU.
THEIR SMEARS, THEIR LIES,
THEIR CONSPIRACY THEORIES
THEY ARE NEVER-ENDING.
BY THE WAY, NOW YOU ARE PART
OF IT.
REALLY?
YOU DON’T THINK QUID AND PRO
AND QUO JOE, YOU ARE NOT
GETTING THE BILLION UNTIL
YOU FIRE THE PROSECUTOR,
INVESTIGATING MY
ZERO-EXPERIENCED SON BEING
PAID MILLIONS?
YOU JUST EXONERATED THEM.
WOW, GOOD FOR YOU, MITT, YOU
ARE REALLY CONSISTENT.
DO YOU THINK THIS CHARADE IS
OVER NOW THAT THE PRESIDENT
HAS BEEN ACQUITTED?
I HATE TO TELL YOU, THINK
AGAIN.
WATCH THIS.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
ACQUITTED BY THE UNITED
STATES SENATE.
DOUBLE JEOPARDY DOES NOT
APPLY IN POLITICS.
NANCY PELOSI AND IN HER
HOUSE JERRY NADLER SAYING
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE THEY ARE
GOING TO SUBPOENA JOHN
BOLTON IT.
IS RISKY FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
IT’S T-BALL FOR TRUMP TO SAY
THIS IS GREW GRA DO YOU
TUESDAY AND POLITICAL.
IT’S ALSO RISKY FOR ALL
THESE SENATORS WHO JUST
VOTED ON THE PRESIDENT’S
SIDE AS THIS NEW INFORMATION
COMES OUT.
WE SHOULD PAUSE AND REFLECT
ON THE HISTORY OF TODAY IN
THE CONTEXT OF IMPEACHMENT
THIS IS OVER BUT IT’S NOT
OVER.
>> Sean: NO DOUBLE JEOPARDY.
DO IT AGAIN.
JUST KEEP DOING IT.
IT NEVER ENDS.
WITCH-HUNT WILL CONTINUE.
THE HOUSE WILL PROBABLY TRY
TO IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT
OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
AS WE SPEAK, THEY ARE
ACTUALLY LET’S BRING IN JOHN
BOLTON.
HANG ON A SECOND.
LET’S SAY THE PRESIDENT SAID
TO JOHN BOLTON, YOU KNOW
WHAT?
I AM NOT GIVING THEM THE
MONEY UNLESS THEY DO THIS,
THIS, AND.
THIS THE FOUR FACTS NEVER
CHANGE DO THEY AMBASSADOR?
THEY NEVER DID ANYTHING,
THEY NEVER FELT PRESSURED TO
DO ANYTHING.
AND EVEN MORE IMPORTANTLY,
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE TAPE OF
JOE BIDEN AND THE INTERVIEW
OF HUNTER BIDEN, WITH NO
EXPERIENCE AND THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY, THAT’S A PRIMA FACIE
CASE OF CORRUPTION.
THE PRESIDENT ALSO HAS A
SWORN DUTY, AS WE HAVE SAID
FROM THE BEGINNING, TO
FAITHFULLY EXECUTE THE LAWS
AND THAT UKRAINIAN ELECTION
INTERFERENCE STUFF, SEPARATE
AND APART FROM THE RUSSIA
INTERFERENCE, YEAH, THAT
WOULD BE, IF YOU WILL
RECALL, NOT -- JANUARY 11TH,
2017 THE POLITICO.
UKRAINIAN COURT SAID UKRAINE
INTERFERED IN THE 2016
ELECTION TO HELP HILLARY AND
THEY WERE SUCCESSFUL
POLITICO TOLD US.
WOW THAT WOULD BE FAITHFULLY
EXECUTING THE LAWS.
CORRUPT COMPROMISED LIAR BY
THE NAME OF ADAM SCHIFF
ALREADY PLOTTING HIS NEXT
TOP SECRET STYLE HEARINGS.
NOW, FOR YOU WE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
271 DAYS YOU ARE THE
ULTIMATE JURY.
YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SHOCK THE WORLD AGAIN.
AND BY THE WAY REELECT THIS
PRESIDENT WHO HAS
ACCOMPLISHED ALL THE THINGS
WE PUT ON THE SCREEN.
NOW, IF YOU WANT ALL OF THIS
TO END, I HAVE AN ANSWER,
WHEN YOU VOTE FOR DONALD
TRUMP, YOU HAVE ALL THE
POWER, I ONLY HAVE ONE
LITTLE VOTE IN NEW YORK.
YOU CAN ALSO GIVE THE HOUSE
BACK TO THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
A REPUBLICAN MAJORITY FOR
THE PRESIDENT.
AND YOU CAN VOTE FOR
REPUBLICAN SENATORS IN YOUR
STATE WHILE YOU ARE VOTING
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP THE
WITCH-HUNT WILL THEN STOP
AND THEN THE COUNTRY WILL
MOVE FORWARD.
IMAGINE THIS PRESIDENT
ACTUALLY BEING ABLE TO WORK
WITHOUT NEVER ENDING
WITCH-HUNTS, LIES,
CONSPIRACY, HOAXES, MISS
INFORMATION, DISINFORMATION,
EVERY DAY.
WOW, AMAZING WHAT WE CAN
ACCOMPLISH WITHOUT THAT
HOVERING OVER HIS HEAD EVERY
SECOND OF EVERY MINUTE OF
EVERY HOUR OF EVERY DAY AS
THE PRESIDENT SAID DURING
HIS STATE OF THE UNION
ADDRESS THE BEST IS YET TO
COME.
LOWEST LABOR PARTICIPATION
RATE IN THE ’70S.
8 FEWER MILLION AMERICANS ON
FOOD STAMPS.
8 MILLION NEW JOBS.
MILLIONS OUT OF POVERTY.
THE BEST EMPLOYMENT
SITUATION FOR EVERY
DEMOGRAPHIC IN THE COUNTRY
IN 50 YEARS WOW.
WE COULD DO MORE.
GOOD NEWS FOR THE
PRESIDENT’S RE-ELECTION BID
THAT IS THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
IS A TRAIN WRECK IN EVERY
ASPECT.
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
TAKE OVER YOUR HEALTHCARE
AND GIVE NOW CHOICE IN
HEALTHCARE AND CONTROL EVERY
MAJOR INDUSTRY IN THE U.S.,
IT COULDN’T EVEN COUNT A FEW
THOUSAND VOTES IN THE STATE
OF IOWA.
NOW, THE OFFICIAL TALLY
DELAYED FOR SEVERAL DAYS,
FINALLY THEY GOT TO
100 PERCENT.
THEY JUST DID MOMENTS AGO SO
RIDDLED WITH ERRORS AND
INACCURACIES THE DNC CHAIR
IS CALLING FOR IMMEDIATE
RECANVAS.
OKAY.
LET’S CONTINUE THAT IOWA
CAUCUS SCHIFF SHOW IF YOU
WILL.
DON’T WORRY, DEMOCRATS KNOW
WHO TO BLAME FOR THE
DUMPSTER FIRE IN IOWA.
WITHOUT ANY EVIDENCE, YEAH,
THEY ARE BLAMING, INCLUDING
CONGRESSWOMAN SHEILA JACKSON
LEE, RUSSIA.
AND TRUMP OTHERS ARE BLAMING
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
DOG BITES, BEESTINGS,
FEELING SAD IT’S GOD TO BE
DONALD TRUMP’S FAULT, RIGHT?
BY THE WAY DRINK TOO MUCH
JACK DANIELS OF BEER, DON’T
FEEL GOOD THE NEXT MORNING,
IT’S NOT YOUR FAULT IT’S
TRUMP’S FAULT.
REPORT CLAIMING THAT SOME
SUPPORTERS MIGHT HAVE
ACTUALLY CALLED INTO AN IOWA
DEMOCRATIC HOTLINE AND
CLOGGED UP THE CALLS.
THIS IS A CONSPIRACY.
THE RUSSIANS TOLD TRUMP TO
DO IT.
BY THE WAY, TRUMP MIGHT
ACTUALLY GIVE ALASKA TO
RUSSIA SO THAT RUSSIA HELPS
HIM IN THE 2020 ELECTION.
SCHIFF SAID THAT.
AND, OF COURSE, DEMOCRATS,
THIS DEBACLE WILL PALE IN
COMPARISON TO THE
INTERLOOMING CIVIL WAR.
THEY’RE LOOKING TO ROB
BERNIE AGAIN.
THE DEMOCRATIC ESTABLISHMENT
ONCE AGAIN TRYING TO RIG THE
PRIMARY AGAINST HIM.
WE NEED DONNA BRAZILE TO
COME BANG AND TELL THAT
STORY THAT PHONE CALL SHE
HAD TO MAKE YEAH IT ALL
HAPPENED, BERNIE.
ULTIMATELY, NONE OF IT WILL
HAPPEN.
ULTIMATELY, YOU ARE THE
ULTIMATE JURY.
I KNOW WE ARE SMELLY WALMART
SHOPPERS, GUILTY.
YEP, I CLING TO GOD.
I BELIEVE IN GOD A CREATOR.
I REALLY DO.
CONSTITUTION, SECOND
AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
I BELIEVE IN THE BIBLE.
I BELIEVE IN RELIGION.
I’M IRREDEEMABLE DEPLORABLE
AND WALMART, I SAVE MONEY